I'm not here to murder bend the knee and join me or refuse and die
You need to find a way to make her listen
whoever stands in our way
we will defeat
Bran saw the night King and his army marching towards East watch
Bad things are coming
Bad things are coming everybody let's break this down and be sure to subscribe if you're finding me for the first time
So you start out with Tyrion looking like he's really worried that Daenerys is going to kill Jaime as well as all the other Lannister Soldiers
The way they cut it jumps around in time a little bit so obviously they deal with that
then you hit the varys line where he's talking to Tyrion. You need to find a way to make her listen
And it makes it seem like she's going off the rails but this feels like another version of the drama at Winterfell
Which really wasn't drama to begin with like they hyped it up before the season
So you're like is Sansa going to be fighting with Jon, then you see what that looks like on screen
So they're just trying to make Dany seem like she's slowly going off the rails even though I don't think that's the case
and wouldn't it be great though if Jon Snow is the one to make her listen
because on his advice She went straight to Jaime instead of going to King's landing
So I know there's a big question mark about what happened after that battle but I think all the big characters are still fine
So you have Bronn Jaime then you have the Tarly's I think they're fine, too
You see a couple of them standing right up here at the head as Daenerys talking as I'm telling them they have to bend the knee
or they die so it seems like a little bit of a repeat of Robb stark mistakes
Maybe Daenerys will make a couple mistakes, but I don't think that she's going to kill Jaime
I think he'll be totally fine the producers even said the Jaime is critical to the future of the story
So he has heavy plot armor even though he's sinking to the bottom of that pond however deep it is
Somebody will fish him out. You have Cersei who now has the gold.
You only get that quick scene with Qyburn in that offhanded line
They really lost supplies, but they have the gold to hire the golden company, so it seems like they'll be getting more troops
She was also going to use that to bolster their other forces as well as build more ships
So it seems like a bigger Setback than it actually is but it takes time to build all those things
even if you're Euron Greyjoy and you can build a thousand ships overnight
But really excited to see what happens when Jon snow finally meets Drogon
This is the first time that I think that he's been face to face with the dragons
He's been on dragonstone for a long time
So he's been around the dragons, but this is the first time we actually get to see him up close on screen
He didn't look terrified the first time he saw them mostly just flabbergasted
But as they've been including all kinds of subtle winks at his Targaryen heritage his father this would be a prime place to do that
sometimes those are a little more on the nose and others
like when the lords of the north say a Targaryen can't be trusted just as Jon Snow's giving them this big speech about going to Dragonstone
Or the really on the nose time when he says he's not a Stark just as a dragon swoops down screeching at him
if there were any questions about what happened to Drogon like you see him on the perch here
I love the way this looks like a nest in the background here
That's how big he is but he flew back to dragonstone,
so even though he was wounded by the Scorpion
He will heal and I know there were a lot of questions about why would you call it a scorpion if there wasn't poison in the stinger?
So maybe qyburn who's a master of poisons put something on those iron arrows. It's always possible
I think if they were going to do something like that you would find out relatively quickly
Because a couple weeks seemed to be passing between episodes
But even if Drogon were to eventually die someday the dragons are effectively Sexless
like they can actually mate with each other if they needed to so you can actually make more Dragons
As long as there were two of them still around love the shot of Jon snow at the map table
It feels like they made a new version of the table for this season and obviously they built a bunch of new sets for Dragonstone
Because you've already seen it in several different
Angles and places that we haven't seen before they built the throne room for this year all the cave sets
but you also
Film that table room from different Angles when Stannis was in it before you only saw it when it was really dark
And they filmed him against this wall with the dragon carving in it and that was about it
So it is one of my favorite news sets
And I love the the cave set from last night too. Everybody was making the joke that Jon Snow scribbled all those drawings himself
before daenerys came in to convince her but even though that's kind of ridiculous
Yes, the drawings did look relatively primitive, so I didn't think that was a little bit silly
But they just want to convey the idea that the children of the forest who used to give
Obsidian to the first men probably got a lot of it from Dragonstone before there was ever a castle or a keep there
Based on the readings that Sam has done though
It seems like the valyrians who didn't build an outpost there till thousands of years after the long night
Didn't know anything about the origins of the children of the forest  per se his readings
They would add dragonglass to their structures their buildings without really understanding the mythological
Significance to it. They just used it as a building tool
but speaking of mythology getting into the war for the dawn
Jon mentions Bran saw the night King with the army of the Dead and eastwatch-By-the-sea
So that confirms a couple things they've sent a raven from Winterfell
So he knows that bran is there now he probably also knows that arya is there but Daenerys is still pissed about her war with Cersei
So it sounds like there's still going to be a lot of back-And-forth about what they do next
Knowing that there's an army of the dead and how they get everybody on the same page
So this sounds like where we get to our plan where you see Jon Snow in this small band of people north of the wall with Tormund
So just a quick reminder that the wildlings have already gone to eastwatch-by-the-sea
That's why you haven't seen them too much this season. Tormund has that line where he says I guess
We're the nights watch now. So at some point you have to sync back up with that storyline
so we'll see How quickly they make a beeline for the wall
But there's still all this stuff going on with Cersei in the battle from last week that they have to resolve first
looking at the Ravens fly over seems like it's
Connected to the scenes from the trailer that we saw earlier this year where the night king turns and looks up watching
Bran while he's watching him so it's a bit strange they didn't include him in the trailer
So it sounds like they just want you to think about what's going on south of the wall is a bigger part of the plot
Than what's going on North like still pushing that off towards the end of the season
Because last week's episode was so short
We didn't get any Samwell seen so I'm expecting him to come back he tends to find something really cool or critical information in
Every episode that he's in so just expecting another big revelation or a teaser bomb
like gilly here reading all about azor Ahai them reading about the history of the kingdom still kind of
Disappointed about the greyscale thing, but whatever insert Jorah has been making his way back to dragonstone it seems
So maybe we'll see him turn up too, but he's nowhere in the preview here
So the only other thing I heard people really wondering about after last week's episode is whether or not Tyrion is going to try and help Jaime escape
I do think that Jaime is going to make it back to King's landing
But I think if he did something as crazy as releasing Tyrion the way the catelyn stark released Jaime
Then I think that she would be more pissed about Tyrion in these later scenes when they're back on Dragonstone
Like I said, I think there'll be a little bit of tension between Tyrion and Daenerys
But it'll be tension in the way that there was tension between Jon Snow and Sansa
Ultimately I don't think he's going anywhere people are like is he in a defect what's going on?
No, I don't think it's going to be anything so serious. So leave all your questions in the comments
I've already gotten a couple requests for bonus videos that I'll probably do later this week
But my Q&A video will post tomorrow just like normal so anything you want me to include in that just leave that in the comments
Congratulations to the latest HBO now, Giveaway winner Matthew BBender
Please private message me on the back end of my channel so I can get your contact details
While you wait for everything you can click here for my episode 4 video and you can click here for my episode 3 video
Thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight